l'europe était déchiré avec d'autres
courageux robert schuman a rassemblé il
a uni pour que la paix sans racines 71
ans après le chemin parcouru est immense
l'unité la solidarité sont notre moteur
il nous reste beaucoup à faire
la renaissance européenne est devant
nous 71 ans après l'union européenne vit
l'une des plus graves crises de son
histoire après la crise financière de
2008 la crise migratoire de 2015 voilà
que la crise sanitaire liée au kobus 19
fait voler en éclats l'unité et la
solidarité affichée par emmanuel macron
il y a un an l'europe s'écharpent sur le
moindre équipement médical tant les
pénuries sont criantes
quelques mois plus tard bruxelles rate
le coche de la vaccination négociations
tardives trop-plein de procédures manque
de pragmatisme et les campagnes de
vaccination dans les pays de l'ue eux
patine comparée à celle menée tambour
battant au royaume uni qui venait de
quitter l'union
elles vont entraîner une pluie de
critiques sur la commission jusqu'à même
se faire remonter les bretelles par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé les
vaccins sont notre meilleure voie pour
sortir de la pandémie
non seulement ils fonctionnent mais ils
sont aussi très efficaces pour limiter
les infections
néanmoins le déploiement de ces vaccins
est d'une lenteur inacceptable l'europe
des 27
unie et solidaire montre rapidement ses
failles
la hongrie tout de suite décide de faire
cavalier seul en homologuant le vaccin
russe spoutnik vais non autorisée par
l'union européenne les pays qui ont
acheté par eux mêmes de leur propre
initiative des vaccins sans arrière
idéologique en se tournant notamment
vers les vaccins produits par la russie
et la chine s'en sortent mieux et les
britanniques qui ont quitté les lieux à
la fin de l'année 2020 aujourd'hui sont
à un niveau de vaccination quatre fois
supérieur à la france l'allemagne
l'italie ou l'espagne la slovaquie lui
emboîte le pas et l'allemagne se dit
prête elle aussi a commandé le vaccin
reçu une fois qu'il sera autorisée par
bruxelles alors que la france
elle s'entête à garder sa ligne anti
russe à la manière dont ces gérer c'est
plus un moyen de propagande et de
diplomatie agressive qui a moyen de
solidarité dead sanitaires en ce qui
concerne le vaccin russe je suis d'avis
que tout vaccin autorisé par l' agence
européenne du médicament devrait être
utilisée dans l'union européenne
je préférerais une commande de l'union
européenne mais si celle ci
n'intervenait pas alors l'allemagne
devrait agir pour elle même et c'est ce
que nous ferions don du ciel pour les un
outil de propagande pour les autres le
vaccin russe spoutnik v est loin d'être
le seul sujet de désaccord parmi les 27
le pass vaccinale est tout autant
plébiscité que critiquer certains
estiment qu'il est nécessaire pour
accélérer la réouverture des frontières
du tourisme et le retour à la vie
normale
il est urgent d'adopter en accord commun
sur la manière dont un certificat de
vaccination doit être structuré de sorte
qu'ils soient acceptés dans tous les
états membres
le certificat vert européen vise à
revenir à un début de normalité la
france l'allemagne ou les pays-bas se
sont montrés plus prudents finalement
les eurodéputés ont opté pour un
passeport sanitaires européens moins
contraignant il devrait contenir
plusieurs informations personnelles nom
prénom date de naissance numéro de
passeport le type de vaccin à réaliser
ou encore l'état du test pcr
si l'union européenne devraient survivre
à cette énième crise une chose est sûre
elle y aura laissé quelques plumes